north las vegas police are helping  students get ready for the new school  year  they held a back to school revival event  today and saw a huge turnout look at  that  not only were tons of school supplies  given out but they also offered free  haircuts for kids  coveted vaccines along with dental and  vision checks  the event was designed to help families  as they send their kids back to the  classroom  after a tough year this really helps  them because  we couldn't really do too much like when  they went going back to school  and like i said you know we pay bills a  lot of stuff so coming  up here it was we took advantage of it  so they could all get a  school supplies this was the first cops  back to school revive event put together  by north las vegas city council  and police